well the primary objective of the World
Bank is to help developing countries
grow and develop and our main objective
is to help countries reduce poverty so
the World Bank has a long history of
working in China on different types of
projects that have helped reduce poverty
but personally I interpret this mandate
quite broadly I moved to China three
years ago for this assignment and I've
come to think that the key challenge the
China faces is really Environmental
Management natural resource scarcity
water energy these key resource issues
so i think that the impressive poverty
reduction that china has achieved is not
going to be sustainable unless china
really comes to grip with these
environmental challenges so on a
practical level I've you know tried to
shift our world bank program to support
a lot of different environmental
activities in China in the water sector
developing new energy sources now for
example we financed the first big wind
power wind power station in China and
demonstrated that this is economically
viable we finance different types of
clean energy technologies so I guess I
see what I'm doing is working with
Chinese partners to help them address
some of their key challenges and that
goes beyond environment but a lot of our
work now is focused on the environmental
area
you